this Desmond came here from the Los
Angeles chargers I'm here a bleacher
report with building my squad I got $15
I'm going to build my all time chiefs
and 49ers team
my first pick I'm gonna go pack my home
I go at Pat because I actually put I
played I played against Pat and I can
see this guy he's an unbelievable
talented player he make passes on the
throw he came to throw of both hands
left and right so that's why my next big
gonna be Jerry Rice
I picked Jerry Rice because he's a hard
time receiver the greatest receiver to
play the game
tell him to athlete time it's a player
time it's a person
it's Jerry Rice why wouldn't you gotta
spend big bucks on good players next
where I received number two Tyree Gill
great receiver good speed take the top
off take the speed take the top off you
know he's gonna make every catch play
you just throw it deep
I got patching my home to do it for him
five six
I'm gonna go some dbe's burnt Hanks
great DB great player mer Hanks I
watched a little bit of tape on them on
YouTube
I ain't watch it in person but all you
to cost some good stuff great player I
used to see them all the NFL backyard
game so I know ya he'd get the work done
for so that's three Oh Ronnie Lott oh
wait no I ain't got nothing running like
I don't know I ain't got no I'll take it
off oh yeah I ain't got enough for a lot
yeah I was not gonna go ride a lot all
right I'm gonna go reach the server on
the other side there I got two dollars
for that Richard sir me you know I feel
like you know he had a good comeback
story you know tore his Achilles you
know left Seattle made his own deal with
49ers and just had a significant
fantastic season this year and let us
defense to the Superbowl so I got one
dollar to spin honorable mention we're
going tomorrow Charles got to have a
running back so starting with my
all-time quarterback you know I got
Patrick my home
the arm telling the player you know god
I can make any pass that you want
I got Jerry Rice my two receivers Jerry
Rice and Tiger Hill I got speed on one
side and I got good hands on the other
side great hands and my to DBS I got
Richard Sherman
I got Mary Hanks to lock down DBS
there's Desmond came here closing out
from the Los Angeles chargers and this
is build my squad what bleacher report